many people are
living under different multiple layers
of fear one of those fears is about what
happens if you acknowledge your doubts
and indeed you are being encouraged to
believe that what happens if you
acknowledge your doubts is going to be
dire and we're not going to tell you
that there are not serious consequences
there are and we've experienced them
however there is another side
to the puzzle which is how you will feel
when your doubts are no longer a secret
that you are afraid is going to be
discovered and that's what the quote
from
from catch 22 reveals yeah okay let's do
it so this is from this is from the
middle of the book
i forgot the chapter
it's
nope it's not milo the mayor
it's natalie's old man
not reading the whole chapter just about
a page here
so this is um
this is a young this is uh
19 yeah go for it uh you wouldn't set up
the whole book
oh sure no no i thought that's what you
were about to do
no i was just gonna set up the scene
okay so the scene involves uh one of
these young pilots pilots had a very
very dangerous role uh in in world war
ii um a lot of them did not come back
most of them did not come back so it was
a very terrifying thing and this
exchange takes place um hold on so it's
a piece of fiction but heller himself
was was he a bombardier
uh he was he was i think he was in plans
but i don't remember um in any case
the exchange takes place uh obviously if
you're a pilot you're
unless you're based on an aircraft
carrier based on land but this is the
equivalent of shore leave where they've
gone into into italy
and they're at the [ __ ] house and the
old man is the proprietor of the [ __ ]
house and i believe he's talking to
nately is that right
nate lee is a a young gun at a 20-ish
year old
uh guy who is basically pontificating on
his understanding of how the world works
and this uh extremely old uh man the
proprietor of a whorehouse who knows a
whole lot about how the world actually
works um
responds and says all kinds of
interesting sometimes hilarious things
and anyway this this exchange takes
place
yeah i mean it goes on for a long time
i'm just going to read the short little
bit here
the old man says about someone who um
had risked his life you see imagine a
man his age risking what little life he
has left for something so absurd as a
country
natalie was instantly up in arms again
there is nothing so absurd about risking
your life for your country he declared
isn't there ask the old man what is a
country a country is a piece of land
surrounded on all sides by boundaries
usually unnatural englishmen are dying
for england americans are dying for
america germans are dying for germany
russians are dying for russia there are
now 50 or 60 countries fighting in this
war surely so many countries can't all
be worth dying for
anything worth living for said nately is
worth dying for
and anything worth dying for answered
the sacrilegious old man is certainly
worth living for you know you're such a
pure and naive young man that i almost
feel sorry for you how old are you 25 26
19 said natalie i'll be 20 in january
if you live the old man shook his head
wearing for a moment the same touchy
meditating frown of the fretful and
disapproving old woman
they're going to kill you if you don't
watch out and i can see now that you are
not going to watch out why don't you use
some sense and try to be more like me
you might live to be 107 too
because it's better to die on one's feet
than to live on one's knee neatly
retorted with triumphant and lofty
conviction i guess you've heard that
saying before
yes i certainly have used the
treacherous old man smiling again but
i'm afraid that you have it backwards
it is better to live on one's feet than
die on one's knees
that is the way the saying goes
it is better to live on one's feet than
die in one's knees that uh that line has
given me chills for
i don't know
three decades three and a half decades
since i first read it there's something
about it the idea that we have this
thing encoded in our minds about you
know it's uh better to die on one's feet
than live on one's knees and that in
fact we don't even notice this other
possibility right it's ruled out by the
way that the initial thing is phrased
and the point is
um
well i guess it's another version of
plato's cave in some sense right the
idea that there's this other reality
that you can't quite see but if you knew
what it was you would value things very
very differently well it raises
questions of whether or not where you
are at the moment like
are you on your feet or are you on your
knees like that that is the sort of
plato's cave what world is it what
looking glass have you or have you not
gone through
you know what what is your situation
right now how free are you
yeah how free how free are you and
you know it's funny i i have never
thought of it this way
before i've long loved catch 22 there's
so much in it you know it's so
brilliantly done where you know the word
play is
wonderful and the comedy is
utterly hilarious and
plenty dark and all of that but
um but i've never thought of it as a
dystopian novel before but i'm beginning
to wonder you know i'm i'm hearing
discussions about
um about dystopia and about what we are
facing and i think everybody who gets it
realizes
it's not orwellian it's not kafka right
it's it's not huxley it's pieces of
these things it's a hybrid between these
things but the hybridization goes beyond
those classics right it definitely
extends to brazil right there's an
element about this that is
the movie that is that is brazil that's
the yeah brazil the movie but also catch
22 right
and i think the point is how many of
these great um
uh texts or whatever they are does one
need to have a piece that covers all of
the things that we're uh encountering
and then you know if you know i i do
long for
a circumstance in which we have all had
enough shared grounding that we can have
the conversation right that you can say
kafka trap and it doesn't you know leave
a third of the audience wondering what
the heck you're talking about
well that of course is some of what um
you know stereotypically conservatives
bemoan about the loss of
a classic great books curriculum for
instance right that there was
that there was a shared
cultural set of knowledge
that you could know if you were
interacting with people from the same
rough sort of cultural class
uh they they would know and frankly uh
this is this was also true about
uh
what like from our childhoods like
must-see tv
right you know thursday night on nbc
uh everyone watched the same stuff such
that if you had the kind of job that had
a water cooler the next day
you all had seen
you know the huxtables on the cosby show
the night before and you all could talk
about these you know fictional people um
who were who were imagined to be living
lives but you know they were as if
friends so you know your work your
workplace brought together all these
people who lived separate lives but they
had this shared
thing that was that was brought into
their in their homes every every
thursday
and
of course you know both the loss of both
um
classic traditional curricula
and of
uh
television or other media that actually
comes in at a particular moment as
opposed to when it is that you have the
time
uh you know both of which have reason
the changes
the reasons for the changes are not
entirely bad right and the changes
themselves are of course not entirely
bad but there are trade-offs and we have
we there is very little now that
synchronizes us
well um except for this forced consensus
that we are told we are all synchronized
we all know that you know the un's are
dirty right when we are synchronized by
something that is that is the opposite
of education right it is it is
miseducation or something like it i have
to say that when whenever you say
curricula i think of an academic vampire
i just can't help but curriculum yeah um
female presumably
no but that's great well i guess
dracula's not yeah no
maybe he is now but um
perhaps yes perhaps um who's to say
dracula only dracula yes um lived
experience being primal right not primal
uh
unlived experiences
[Laughter]
oh boy all right good uh but too late
for halloween yeah we're there right in
time for thanksgiving halloween is the
unlived experience yes um
all right so the point i wanted to make
i have i have also made this this point
about um
you know the uh the shared
the shared um
god doesn't play dice but fairfax does
he sure does um he's now about to eat a
rubber band that could end badly um what
has gotten into all of us this week
really so i think the problem is the
conservatives don't have it right right
the great books curriculum is not the is
not the curriculum for modern times
neither is the um
the
liberal arts uh grab bag
right and the point is so i don't know
what you mean by the liberal arts grab
bag i mean
as i've said a number of times i think
liberal arts
is
the central concept of liberal arts
which is basically a an education that
is not about training you
uh is correct but that liberal arts
itself learning how to think and um yeah
helping revealed to you
what you can and cannot do and it is
about upgrading the mind
um and
the
problem with it is that upgrading the
mind you know
gets into a question of okay what is
what do we regard as an upgrade right
and the point is
i would say any
uh education that does not give you
basic competence in scientific thinking
and math is as a failure right if a
liberal arts education can include an
education that doesn't have that then
it's a failed concept to me but anyway
the point is what we need is some sort
of
great book some hybrid between a liberal
arts style thinking which is too
flexible because it doesn't give us a
shared set of
concepts that allows us all to interact
with the same baseline
right
and then the great books thing the
problem with that one is that it is too
grounded at the moment that you declare
these books great and the point is the
amount of
the amount that we know about the
universe is changing and so what are the
chances that that
group of books that one most ought to
prioritize is static
what it really is is it has to be a
dynamic frame that still prioritizes the
sharedness and you know your point about
must-see tv
um i agree and the point is musty tv i
don't think it was except it wasn't
important it wasn't good
but but much more important
than
good is
shared in some sense and i've said this
about books themselves that in some
sense the the the
important thing is that people have
have been run through the same
experience so that they have a basis for
interacting over it rather than
everybody having an a la carte
experience
which can be a higher quality experience
because it's tailored to you but it
means that you know the us part doesn't
work as well so
yeah um there is something to having at
least you know you know i've made the
point that uh
musically the era of lps and a small
number of radio stations which dispensed
music into your car in your house
was not that wasn't a natural moment
right it seems more natural than our
current moment but no it's just the
moment we were born into and the point
was though that you know there's nothing
natural about having every radio station
playing stairway to heaven during a
particular month because it's the latest
craze but it did give you know it meant
that if you met somebody from a
different high school they were also
having a piece of the same experience it
also allows you to place your memories
in time later right um like you know we
stairway to heaven was big when we were
tiny kids so you know we weren't we
weren't around for that moment but
um
you they're
in in the 80s when we were in high
school
um
there
there was a soundtrack to that era uh
that frankly a lot of retail stores are
now playing you know like we are the
target audience for a lot of a lot of
retail stores
and it pulls you right back
right it builds you right back and that
is to some degree true now of course
like there's music coming out right now
that will only ever have come out in
2021 because that's just what history
and the you know the truth of time and
reality is um but there's so much of it
and it's so
sort of desynchronized
uh that there won't be there can't be a
like oh you know remember remember the
month
that
all the radio stations were suddenly
playing x and also you know the
earthquake happened in y
and that happens to be the month that i
broke up my first boyfriend or oh really
because that was the month that i first
tried sushi you know whatever it is like
you you can come together over like okay
there are these universals
and they're not just
an earthquake and why they're also
things that actually tug at the deepest
emotional truths which is often music
yeah right
and so we we can synchronize with those
things even with people who we didn't
know at the time because they were
experiencing the same thing the same
emotional thing the same musical thing
at the time and that that is one of the
desynchronizations and therefore i think
the decoherences
of modernity yes with with globalization
of media and social media um surpassing
most um most other kinds well we are
seeing two things at once we are seeing
the market deliver because markets feed
individuals because it is individuals
usually who do the spending right it is
feeding us something that tickles our
particular fancy which is separating us
it's it's decohering us at the same time
it's dispensing
mind-numbing narratives where there is
nothing but questions to be asked
there's no question asked and the
narrative is dispensed as if it was
obviously true and anybody who departs
from this has lost their freaking mind
right so it's the worst of both worlds
right
we don't know each other well and yet we
all believe the same [ __ ]
[Music]
you